this
is star talk i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
and this is going to be a cosmic queries
edition
fan favorites and they've been that way
ever since we began these many years ago
my co-host my comedic co-host for this
episode
is nagin farsad nagin welcome to star
talk
oh my god hello and we're in the
coronaverse so we're all separated
uh where are you right now i'm actually
in um
a studio in manhattan a recording studio
because i'm in the middle of doing an
audio book with a sultry voice of mine
i'm working i'm in the middle of a gig
it's new and different to be outside of
my apartment
wow because i you know i knew comedians
had gigs i didn't know they had actual
jobs
this is this is a gig though right this
is a gig no no comedians aren't good
enough to have jobs
okay that's what i thought that's what i
thought you just you know you get what
comes your way
day day by day um so you you have a
podcast with the greatest name ever fake
the nation
thank you love your host of that podcast
and you wrote a book
how to make white people laugh you guys
you got to buy that book just
just to know what i think you should
just
yeah because it'll tell you how to do it
and then it'll be really useful
information
it's always good to make your bookshelf
look fun
yeah and and people laughing is a um
that warms them up to receive other
information that they might
need exactly i think you know a little
something about that because sometimes
you need to make them laugh before you
can
douse them with science exactly exactly
and you're uh for fans of the show you
are a
uh a recurring guest on npr's wait wait
don't tell me
um fan favorite out there in there
so you're here and you're gonna help us
um bring questions
to our special guest she's a returning
guest on star talk and it's anissa
ramirez and he said welcome back to star
talk
hey neil how are you so glad to be here
in the coronaverse yeah i know and it's
been too long
it's been years since we've had you on
uh you're a material scientist and
engineer
and you've got a pie but he's got a
podcast host of the podcast science
underground it's not just studying caves
or anything like that
no no caves no caves give me a one
sentence accounting of science
underground
science underground explains science in
two minutes so we'll explain how
tires are made from lettuce and how
leaves change color
wow okay i'll watch some of that
i thought i thought where the name like
science underground would be some sort
of like
punk science movement you know yeah
something
something counter cultural so you got a
ways to go there
okay i'm working on it baby steps
you gotta punk it up
and the reason why we caught up with you
again is because you have a new book out
just published
this year and it's uh i get the title
right
the alchemy of us this is my baby
oh how humans and matter transformed
one another great title and so
so uh when you read that book forgive me
i haven't read it because i
learned about it only just a couple of
weeks ago um what how will you be
changed for having read this book
you're going to look at technology
differently you're going to see that it
actually shaped us
simple things like the telegraph shaped
language the light bulb
is actually changing our health and our
computers are changing the way we
remember
things so we're going to have a new
relationship with the things that are
around us
that's such an engineering thing to do
well good thing i'm an engineer
but i just want people to have a new
approach to technology we we're
wowed by them and that's perfectly fine
but also know that we're actually in a
relationship with these
technologies and so what this this is
what this book highlights what nakeen do
you have a relationship with technology
i mean like in that i have to stare at a
screen
like all the time yeah
i have a love hate relationship with
with technology
i have i'm one of those people that like
wishes i
died before computers like i was born
too late
wow so anissa is there an
age threshold below which
they um they're incapable of uttering
what's just said about i wish i was born
before computers
i haven't heard that that would be a
great quote on this front of the book i
wish i was born before computers
or something like that maybe in the next
edition i'll have nagin come on board
again
because
i know is that sacrilege i don't think
so
as a writer i mean when i was writing
the book i was using old tech i was
using pencils and index cards because
that's what my brain could handle and
i'm sure maybe younger folks would use
computers and you know different ways of
databases but
you know so you have to do what you feel
comfortable with remember when we used
to all have
handwriting what's that
like where you actually used to know how
to like hold pencils and stuff
i just is this how you decide
it just looks like a stick i don't think
computers started this
issue okay before printing
the printing press everything was
handwritten and so handwriting was an
art and you would have illuminated
manuscripts with artwork on the side
and then out you could write a word
in a scripty way to convey an emotion
beyond just the pure definition of the
word
right so writing itself was was a
multi-dimensional mode of communicating
then you had a printing press
now letters just get stamped okay and
now you can
flourish them and then okay so that took
that out
and now people forgot or lost how to
communicate emotions now you have emojis
right right well that's one of the
things i discussed in the alchemy of us
that we're actually losing
our ability to empathize because as
you're talking about these different
layers of communication that we use are
being removed as we move from the
printing press to
to to our computers today and what we
need is we need to look at each other
and also be able to communicate with our
body language so i'm totally on board
with what you're saying
we have to actually look at each other
i'm taking notes with my quill pen of
everything you say
can i tell you though anissa i think you
would like this that when my dad
met my mom they're iranian immigrants on
iran he was really into calligraphy and
he wrote her a little book of poetry and
with all the flourishes that neil talked
about with the flowers on the side and
little like
you know just the the stuff of
calligraphy and be all of this in
beautiful
you know uh farsi text um and then you
know
it worked on her she married it worked
out
so get yourself i got to show you i got
to show you something hang on a sec
get yourself a quill if you like one
because an emoji is just not going to
have the same effect
oh wait a minute wait a minute do you
have a collection
so i um i love calligraphy
and quill pens and so uh i have a whole
supply of them
just for for the you know the emergency
case where you need to
listeners were looking at a bunker's
worth of feather
pens in neil's office
i'm ready for the coronaverse when all
printing presses are down that's right
that's right
he's making his own ink
so uh nadine you collected questions for
for this q a
for this cosmic queries what was the
theme would you just was it just
um technology in modern times
technology and how it's connected to
humans well let's do that so
all these questions will be for anissa
occasionally people slip in something
that where i can jump in
but basically oh there were plenty of
questions that were for you
like dark matter i was like i know who's
gonna answer that one
so go for it um i'm gonna start um
with a question from a patreon a
listener um
elaine asks has technology affected our
biology
like our actual biology oh i like that
one
me too it has it has actually
researchers say that we are slightly
taller than our ancestors and one of the
reasons besides nutrition and water and
better medicines is actually the light
it actually it ends up that we have two
modes we have a daytime mode and a
nighttime mode we have a growth mode and
we have a rest mode
and the growth mode is instilled by blue
light
which is from the sun but also
artificial lights have a lot of blue
light and since we're under artificial
lights most of the time
we grow and so here's how our biology
has been affected by a simple simple
device of
the electric bulb i'm annoyed because
i'm five foot three and a half so i feel
like my body did not get that memo
yeah you have to get out more just get
out more okay
i know i've been hanging out in caves
too much
listening to science underground see i
told you get out
wait but so all right that's one aspect
of it but what about
um okay here's something i don't know
how old the two of you are but i'm old
enough to remember
that if you were clumsy
someone would say hey you're all thumbs
but then when video games came out and
the thumb is a fundamental part
of the utility and your dexterity
to say your all thumbs in a modern
context might mean you are highly
dexterous
that's a good point it's true well is
that in your book
no it's only 300 pages i didn't get to
the hand
the thumb part i think it's in the thumb
part but maybe if there's a new addition
but the but the hand eye coordination
achieved at a young age uh you know you
look at it's in the military drone
pilots are way back in some base camp
and they're they're basic they're
they're control they're flying an
airplane
right as though it's a video game did
you
is there any understanding of whether
our brains are different because of
technology
well uh what you use a lot you
enhance so if they've been training and
been doing this for some time
they will have a higher level of being
able to do that than if someone just
walks up and tries to fly a drone
okay so so the whole world of video
games where parents are always
complaining that the kids are spending
too much time on
they're actually training for jobs
pretty much
but don't tell them that we still want
them to get off and do their homework
all right uh so so the the future of
this i mean you gave
you gave um basic biological examples
but you can imagine a future which
everyone talks about i don't think it's
coming but people like to talk about
when they inject a chip into your brain
right so you merge the biology and the
technology into one functioning
entity because it's just electrochemical
is do you see that as
an inevitable step into the future
that's what scientists would like
um you know whether it's a good good
idea or not that's still something
that's for debate
uh but i do know without even including
the chip our brains are actually being
rewired by the internet
uh i can give you an example i often ask
people i say you know tell me
tell me your mother's phone number and
most people will say well they don't
know their mother's
phone number they love their mother but
what they've done is they they've offset
that information to their cell phones
but i remember my childhood phone number
so
because of the internet because of its
pervasiveness and the fact that we can
recall
have access to it all the time our
memories have changed we don't
remember what the information is but
where the information is so we've
already been rewired
einstein is rumored for having said uh
never memorize
anything that you can just look up
why isn't apple using that in their
advertising
einstein was born too early
yeah we should have really been
indifferent
this was all messed up can i say though
that i don't
think that i do you know i do feel like
we're going in that being chipped
direction
the way you're talking about neil but i
i still feel like
there there's backlash to that like
remember when google came out with
glass and at first everyone's like ooh
glass but then
immediately once started people wearing
them people called those
wearers glass holes you guys remember
this wow
yeah there was a backlash people were
like no
don't merge your bot like don't have a
thing on your body that does the thing
and so i feel like people you know
they have some limits so what you're
saying is that the
uh enough to put words in your mouth but
you're saying if you remember me
because you had to look me up in your
database
then the pretense that you have some
fond
uh thoughts about our last encounter are
false
and that fact was transparent to
everybody
is is that what you're saying there yeah
i'm
yeah i mean because it's sort of like
when a politician is
glad handing like at a big rally and
there's always like a person right
behind them whispering like this person
is from
you know right right this person's one
of your donors that's like what we're
getting and we know that the politician
is fake
you know right we know there's not very
much sincerity in that so that's
basically
just making it yeah yeah you're just
being a glasshole
i remember those people on planes i
think they also the backlash is that
they were recording people in front of
them all the time
and you wanted to be able to have
control over your image being captured
all the time and
and being lifted up into the cloud so it
was it was both those things it was
you know having these fake interactions
but also you stealing my
my likeness for whatever use okay so how
about this then
um like in the movie avatar uh
where where the the the the
aliens the the life forms there had like
these usb
ponytails right and they would plug it
into like the
right they plug it into stuff and they
would connect and then they would be
able to communicate
and so if we had it like a usb
port and we plugged in the internet so
that we can
gain immediate access to information so
i'm not
uh it's really just for research i guess
rather than for social interaction
what do you think of that what are we
doing with all that information
most of the most of the time i see
people playing games
i don't know who you're hanging out with
leo
i'm seeing this and they're just you
know it's candy falling from the sky
um people are actually going to use that
information to do something and to
create
i'm all for it because you have access
to the entire planet
but we don't use the internet in a way
that's actually meaningful so
that's the thing i i push back with you
know i play this game with my friends
called the human google and it's
essentially we have a conversation
and never look anything up
we just try and remember we're just
trying to remember
what a concept it's called the brain or
something wow
so i've always wanted to introduce
something similar to that not as severe
because uh you're you're over you're you
crossed over there over the top
yeah what i would do is you say if if an
argument begins
someone usually quickly goes to their to
their google search and i say no
we we should argue this for at least 10
minutes
right forcing you to get to to dredge
memory
to figure stuff out and you get to learn
that whoever is the loudest isn't always
the one who's correct
so to calibrate people's capacity to
argue
based on what they think is true right
this is very useful this is very useful
so yeah oh that's great because if you
don't practice that you're going to lose
that
ability that's what we learned about the
brain the brain is this wonderful thing
it's called plastic it will change
if you give it a new talent a new skill
it will enhance it but if you stop using
that skill
it will it will lessen don't call my
brain plastic
hey hey man your grain is plastic in a
good way
it's a compliment it's it's bundy it's a
ben
it can change and enhance but uh but if
you don't it can also
it'll also stay in a landfill forever
and float in the ocean
so guys we've got to take a quick break
when we come back more q a
for anissa ramirez engineer material
scientist
on star talk
we're back star talk neil degrasse tyson
i'm here with my
co-host negin farsad nadine welcome to
star talk
what do you do do you tweet i presume
what's your twitter handle
my twitter handle is at nagin farsad a
name that is both easy to pronounce and
spell
uh that that is any g-i-n-f-a-r-s-a-d
on the twitters i say things excellent
excellent and anissa you're our special
guest today
uh it's not often we have an engineer on
the program it's great to almost
i have more scientist friends than
engineering friends
not nothing against you and your and
your kind
we're a special kind special kind um
so uh we're discussing the
ideas that are explored in your book
give me the full title again here it's
called the alchemy of us
how humans and matter transform one
another that's a brilliant title
can you see the cover kind of looks like
the periodic table this is a link to you
oh very nice very nice hey you there
would be gold
hey that's what i'm talking about
you're talking nerdy to me yeah you
orium for gold
that's right i feel alienated i just
want you both to know did we just leave
you out of that
we're back
we will drift back but only when we feel
like
okay so this is cosmic query so negan
you got another question for me
i do um we're going to take another
question from a patreon listener
um richard russo asks what would you say
was the single greatest advancement in
technology that propelled us
further than any other i love that
question
the tough one that is a tough one and
it's it's really down to opinion
and so as a material scientist i would
probably say steel
steel allows us to have railroads so
that we can connect this huge country
steel also allowed us to have tall
buildings with skyscrapers
before steel buildings were no taller
than nine stories tall
so those two things the railroads
skyscrapers department stores that's
commerce
this small material made all this this
made this economy grow so that would be
my vote
so you couldn't build taller buildings
because the structural integrity of what
was used before
bricks and things that's right would not
support the weight
you you could use stone but the rooms on
the first floor would be
very very small because you needed a lot
of stone to hold up all of that weight
right right but i live in a building
where
uh it's it's a stone building right
i look at the blueprints for every floor
as it gets higher and higher
and in my apartment line you say hey
wait a minute they got more space than
me
it's not their fault it's architecture
but we have really thick walls and you
can't hear the neighbors
so it works out great yeah free war
so how about you uh negan what what
would you think is the
most important oh my gosh i mean i was
that steel thing really uh by the way
when was steel
created yeah yeah when do we take that
steel
rail steel's been around for a while i
would say late
the late 1700s but when we the way to
make
a lot of it was in 1850 in the 1850s
that was henry so then there was all
this stuff that happened before
the 1850s um and all this advancement
i guess i mean you sort of me i don't
know you sort of mentioned this before
neil
but the printing press i feel i feel
like that's a big one because
people were like oh let's form a
government i like what
how would people even know what our
constitution is we'll print it we've got
this printing press
right and then like oh we're just gonna
hand them out like yeah like brochures
what's a brochure you know everyone was
learning
yeah what's a newspaper you know yeah
[Laughter]
so that was a big one definitely the
printing press the printing press also
helped to start
uh religions uh martin luther wanted to
separate
from the standard way of religious uh
religious practice
and so he created these pamphlets as you
talk from catholics
i'm trying not to get attacked but okay
i'm focusing on the technology but yeah
i would say the printing press is
definitely up there
um okay now i have to i've got a i've
got a
i can say you're both wrong i go way
back i'm a way back guy okay
i'm gonna say the wheel and axle oh man
tell me why well because then you can
move stuff you can
build stuff what is this meal i haven't
been outside
so you know don't over don't you know
okay imagine life
before the wheel and life after the
wheel you would say hey i'm living in
the future
look what i can do you know as someone
who has to
stroller a baby through the streets of
new york
the wheel does not always hold up
against potholes
had worse than potholes
the way you do through like an airport
terminal where it's like
butter and you're just like gliding
through like
that's not what it looked like for
prehistoric man with this okay okay
nick green you're not you're not you're
not uh swaying the attitudes of troggs
all right so
what else you got another question oh
another question
okay um let's
go to from
this comes from instagram small talk
small laughs
do you think technology has affected our
very means of life
if so do you think we as a world could
survive in a world with minimal
technology
so another way to ask that maybe is how
much of this is reversible
yes that's a good question
um i think technology's always been
important to us you know starting from
the wheel
and from skins that we use i'm with you
now
making tents you know building fire
these are all technology so technology
has always been important to us but
right now how much is reversible i was
okay in the 80s
um but i don't know if i could live in
the 80s right now or you know with less
tech
i wouldn't be able to connect with my
friends i would be able to go to the
bank
so i think we're kind of on this
escalator where we're all kind of riding
this wave
to however the world will be but we
could have less tech but it would be a
deliberate decision
but but here's what i'm wondering okay
if i'm driving on a country road and i
see a deer
bounding across the road i'd say to
myself wow
that deer doesn't have grocery stores
or internet and it is a
full grown living mammal giving out its
life
right okay here we are in the
coronaverse
and people are hoarding toilet paper and
water
and and i'm imagining what happens
if our grid goes out right what would we
do
can we survive the way the deer can
bounding through the woods
i i don't think so because we don't know
how we don't know how
right the prep know how i wait for the
food to show up
delivered you know i don't go out i
don't hunt for it
i don't that's why you have these
survivalists right they got their guns
and they got there
right you know they'll survive i guess
the rest of us
i don't know we're we're goners
i have no i have honestly no skills
i mean it's remarkable
it's remarkable that i am i can barely
get the cap off of a soda
you know wait wait but negan ever since
the earliest days
of royalty and the like there's always
been a need for comedians
right to and i think because um you can
make fun of me as i can't get a cap off
of a soda like that's
what i'm good for yeah
you know the court jester always had a
job
unless they failed to make the king
laugh right
and they were just beheaded yeah
not to promote myself but i recently
wrote a piece for the progressive
magazine
um called the art of being non-essential
because i think comedians and also
magicians are the least essential
workers right now in society
and my my theory is that if you ever
find yourself in a bunker
with a comedian or a magician like the
first thing you should do
is basically eat that comedian like
that's all we're good for
especially if we've been carb loading
you know
definitely worth it you're the first to
get thrown off the off the life raft yes
exactly funny and delicious
let me try that funny bone
sorry everybody so i got another
question for anisa
another question for anissa so this is
also from instagram
that boy.tristan asks we know that nasa
has contributed to the public with some
of their innovations intended for space
how much has technology created and
innovated for specific
person sorry how much has technology
created and innovated for a specific
purpose
come back around and improve everyday
life
something nasa made has it come back and
made our lives better
well i don't have an example for nasa
but darpa made the internet
and they made that as a way for
scientists all over the world to
communicate with each other to send
this crazy thing called email and then
it became a way to shuttle information
and now we know the internet so this is
it was for a specific use for a small
population for scientists and now
everybody uses it and relies on it so
darpa the the
defense yeah give me the i don't know
the meaning of that
that acronym i just know it is darpa but
it's definitely part of the
department of defense the defense
advanced research project
agency or something right so they they
they have a budget
where they only fund things that are
kind of out of the blue and have a low
chance of succeeding because you need
you need to risk takers out there to
take
high um uh what is it a high risk but
high return right but you don't spend
all that much money on their budget is
relatively low
but but yeah and i always confuse the
internet as a thing with the world wide
web as a thing
because i do know that at cern the
the particle accelerator in switzerland
the physicist there
made major contributions to this
internet thing
so i may be getting those confused but
yeah essentially what i was
trying to get across is that it was
targeted for scientists to communicate
and so with a small pi and then it was
launched into the rest of the world and
it became the thing that we know so so
the questioner is presuming that we want
to invent something for
a purpose and we do it and then it
solves that purpose and then we're all
done and we move on
okay so i got one for you we're throwing
this into the pot um
in in the second world war we learned
that microwaves might be very good at
as a as a means of communicating over
long distances
and in one of the chambers where they're
experimenting with microwaves
someone as the rumor has it they had
left out a chocolate bar
and when they hit a frequency of
microwaves
it melted the chocolate
and then that guy was like hold on let
me go get a hot pocket and see if it
works
exactly the event in the hot pocket
now see how our life has benefited from
the second
so out of that concept came of course
the
the contain microwave oven and the
microwave exists not because anyone
tried to invent it
uh it exists because we saw the the off
ramps from
what it is working with microwaves to
begin with but my
favorite example here is the
uh a physics professor of mine from
college who
specialized in uh the study of molecules
in space
and he discovered a new physics
phenomenon called
magnetic resonance um
nuclear magnetic resonance where where
the nucleus of an atom would
vibrate in a way depending on what kind
of
um energy you passed across it and that
correlation was not previously known
and he won a nobel prize for it nuclear
magnetic resonance
then a a a a medical technician said
wait a minute
if one nucleus vibrates this way and
another vibrates a different way
maybe i can make a cavity and then we
can
identify what atomic nuclei are in the
thing that you put in the cavity
and thus was born the mri the magnetic
resonance imager in hospitals
nice because now you can image things so
you can image soft tissue that x-rays
could not
that's and of course um the original
name of it it had one of the
the n-words you're not supposed to use
like nuclear magnetic resonance
yeah yeah
i got so scared for a second
so they took out the end and now it's a
magnetic resonance imaging the mri
but the full expression of that would be
nuclear magnetic resonance imaging
but no one would no one would go into a
cavity that has the word nuclear on it
that too spooked
well neil i love that your example is
mris
because my example was going to be tang
the orangey drink that i believe
nasa developed for space travel so like
the idea that you could take like a
garbage
orange powder add some water to it and
create a drink
uh i feel like that's something that's
changed our lives yes change your life
i'm interested to learn this about you
and of course a velcro had some good
good applications in space and it's been
it's still used today for so much in
space you know you don't want to have to
uh if things will stick to the wall of
you know of the space station for
example
um without glue without hooks without
it'll just stay there
and the force required to separate it is
not so large that you couldn't
anyone could do it so it turned out to
be quite useful so there's a whole list
of these
um in fact in fact
there's an organization called the space
foundation
which has the space technology hall of
fame
you can just google this um space
intelligence hall of fame in there
are products conceived and invented
for space that have been commercialized
and are making people a buck just in the
in the open marketplace
nice and one of them was temper foam
which was designed to
for impact safety for the for the
cushions
the seats in spacecraft and now people
make mattresses out of it
so right yeah we got to take another
break
uh and when we come back we'll have our
third and final segment of cosmic
queries
the intersection of life and technology
when we return we're back
star talk cosmic queries and we got a
good one going here because
we the the past present and future is on
our table
nagin farsad uh uh my co-host and
comedian and
anissa ramirez out with a new book the
alchemy of us
how humans and matter transformed one
another
so nagin you got another question for
her i do from
uh patrick laby on facebook he asked do
you think that there will be a day when
technology will divide us even more that
the rich will have the majority of it
and the poor will be
outcast and will not have any technology
yeah anissa how much sociology do you
get to in there i
well i i think that i think the question
is very good um i don't talk a lot about
the division of
society uh particularly that topic but i
do think that it's going to continue to
stratify us
in many ways because uh it's a matter of
access to technologies
you need money to do that and so if if
we have a technology and it requires
that you be connected to it and you
don't have the money there's going to be
a further divide between these two
things so
i don't talk about that so much in the
alchemy of us but as i was researching
it i definitely saw how this could
possibly be
a problem uh so isn't that the premise
of avatar neil you mentioned avatar
earlier
okay there was a guy one uh an
ex-military guy who couldn't afford the
operation to get his legs in the future
so they
right principal would be able to do that
so right they were
there was sort of he could not live his
fullest life simply because he
didn't have the money to do so and so
that was sort of a sad element of it but
then
you know all that needed to be writed
was righted by the end of the movie
so that's why i was dwelling on his
issues
right uh that and that's just it's a
biopic of the future so we're all just
gonna have an avatar future
with blue stuff and a quick note here i
learned
i think it was dean caiman who told me
this i hadn't heard it um
was it dean cayman yeah i think was dean
cayman who's
said that initially there's a big divide
between the haves and have-nots for a
new technology
but new technologies never really work
well
all right and so by the time they work
really well
their price has dropped and the company
gets wealthy
not because they're selling it to rich
people but because they're selling it to
everyone
and so now that everyone has a cell
phone a smartphone basically
um you're not looking oh they're rich
they have a smartphone no everybody has
a smartphone
right right and so except for the
poorest of the poor
and so i i was walking the street um
a few months ago before the covert and
a homeless person stopped me and and he
was
laying in the street and it's oh you
you're a neil degrasse ty
yeah and he said yeah i saw you on
netflix it was like
yo you're homeless
explain that one to me
whoever's doing marketing for netflix he
needs to get a nobel prize
really good yeah okay he's good
let's see how many questions we can
squeeze in
we've been luxuriously answering these
questions let's see we can speed it up
okay
this one is a little bit related to what
we're just talking about but
virgil howard um sorry virgil hayward
asks on facebook
kind of a simple question but i often
wonder if we were ready for the
technological era do you believe that we
in this time are mature enough in the
way we use technology
has it been more harmful or useful oh
good one
i don't know if we're it's a matter of
maturity i don't think we're fully
informed
so some of the devices that have come
into our lives we didn't know that we
were actually giving away some of our
privacy
i think that if we knew about that to a
deeper extent then we would make
different decisions
like having those uh devices that record
us and we can make you know have a voice
command
they're also recording us at the same
time and that information is being
stored
maybe if we knew that in much more
detail we could make different decisions
so
it's not a matter of maturity i think
people are mature i think it's they
don't have all the information
so disclosure is a thing definitely
okay but but isn't there a thing with
like we are so addicted to our phones
because like
we're the we're sort of the guinea pig
cohort
we don't know how to put them down or
how to like
you know modulate our use of them
because we're like dumb dumbs and it
came to us
they also have designed these things to
to be addicting
they know that our brains get fired up
when we see
things that give us a sense of success
and award so that's the reason why that
we get pulled in
so sure we may not be we may not
uh be the most disciplined but it's also
that the apps and the like
are also uh taking advantage of that
right so any country that wanted to take
over another country just hand them free
apps
that'll addict them and they won't even
know you're coming i think that's
happening
you weren't supposed to say that
you didn't say that no no scratch that
we'll cut that out in
the edit yes
okay i got another question another
question um this is
also from patreon woody asks and i love
this because
i have questions about conspiracy
theories myself are 5g
conspiracy theorists just luddites and
where does their
and where does their ideology fit into
how technology shapes us
i don't want 5g people coming to my
house so i'll just say that we need to
learn much much more about the
connection between health and 5g and the
thing and
a lot of people are always attaching to
that new thing so that they can
attach their conspiracy on to that but
there's what is the
what is the fear in case listeners don't
know what the fear is about
that birds are going to die that what
have you heard neil i've heard just
um things about our health yeah like you
said a moment ago
it's this it's driven by ignorance of
technology any new technology if it's
not fully explained and people don't
take the time to sit down and recognize
how it works and why it works
you still have people today who put food
in their microwave oven and say they're
nuking it
as though there's some kind of uh you
know nuclear
radiation going on in there and and
that's not the case just simple
microwaves
which you use every day when you use
your your smartphone
um the different frequencies of course
but um
so so um the
china pioneered 5g the way we in america
pioneered
4g lte we pioneered that which enabled
all kinds of streaming
that wasn't previously available whole
companies rose up
within the marketplace exploiting the
bandwidth that that
provided so 5g would take that yet
another notch
except we didn't pioneer that technology
so people are a little spooked
china people they're they're yeah china
spook people
and so um but getting back to the
specifics of the question
um do you see technology as more
susceptible to conspiracy thinking
than other aspects of our lives i i
think so because it's so complex and
people don't understand it
if i said you know the light bulb is
coming into our homes
it would be a little bit of an extension
of what life was like before with gas
lamps and the fireplace and you're like
okay i don't know about a conspiracy
here but now with these technologies
that have tons of code that's so distant
and so unfamiliar
it's easy to latch on to something uh
unfamiliar and say okay well this is the
cause of my ailment or what have you
so we can expect this for every wave
until the technology is so absorbed
that it's just commonplace and no one
thinks about it anymore
or if we start explaining that
anisa has completely lost it
[Laughter]
no but also you know what's weird is
that if people are concerned that
they're they're under mass surveillance
or 5g is going to increase that
surveillance or whatever like
we've already sort of been under mass
surveillance so like
it's not cra it's like these conspiracy
theories end up
feel seeming kind of normal or like
rational
you know and so it's hard sometimes you
know
i think if you really don't know it's
hard sometimes to see the difference if
you have maps operating
in real time in your car to find
grandma's house
um somebody is tracking every how fast
you're going and where you're going
and where you are there's all the three
bits of information anybody wanted to
know about you
so uh yeah you're all that's a great
point
uh you you're already seeding this
content
into the world so anyhow they can
what will happen is they'll refuse to
adopt 5g everyone else will
and they'll get left behind that's
what'll happen that's the op yeah that's
true
yeah well another question i have a
question that is
the logical extension of this one it's
from jacob
owlette on patreon and he has do you
think that the rate at which we continue
to progress in technology
will continue or might it drop off for
some time in the future
i'm sorry or might it drop off sometime
in the future
i don't think technology is going to
slow down i mean maybe now in this
pandemic
it's slowing down a little bit but i
think we're going to continue to do
progress if not what are we going to do
with all these scientists we better keep
them busy
just give them something give them a
prize do something
what did we do with them what did we do
with the scientists during the dark ages
weren't they just like churning butter
instead there were no
in the dark age that's why it's called
the dark ages
but during the war you know they kept
mathematicians busy they're like we'll
make these math tables these very very
thick math tables and you know we use
them today so we've got to keep them
busy
it's a welfare program it is a welfare
program it's a very smart one
i don't i i do feel like there's gonna
be a time where people are just like
forget it i'm joining a commune like i
can see
people just being like i'm going to a
farm none of this is worth it
and uh and then just technology stops
i never met anyone under 30 who came
close to having that thought
[Music]
but then the second they turned 31.
that's that's what it is they're like
think about it if if if you're gonna say
oh my gosh i'm overwhelmed by all this
technology
young people don't think or feel that at
all this
is their life they're not overwhelmed by
it if it is what
they um they're forged
in it so right maybe my generation is
the one that's just feeling a little
overwhelmed by it
and i take a break from it like you know
on sunday i'll just say okay three hours
i'm not gonna look at my phone just
so i my brain will come back yeah just
that's brave of you
i missed it the wrong time something
could happen in those three
something can happen you could miss a
tweet a tweet could go by
what happened oh man
[Laughter]
do we have time for one yeah let's do a
couple more yeah okay
uh so um todd ambrose wrote on facebook
how can we make sure the technology is
used to benefit all humankind and bring
us to a more peaceful and intelligent
rather than dystopian society
todd's watched some movies set in the
future and it's always dystopian yeah
yep oh that's a good question um well we
can always control
technology with our with our purchases
uh if we don't like the way
the way something's going we can not
purchase it or we can encourage other
people not to purchase it
yeah but when bad things happen it's not
because everyone makes a bad thing
happen it's because one person
makes a bad thing happen exploiting the
technology for nefarious
it's a good point so what should we do
about that
i'm asking you you're the engineer
i i think that we should keep an eye on
each other
i also think when we make technology we
should we should we often think that
it's going to be used in positive ways
and we need people who do bad things to
look at a technology and show us okay
how is this going to be used in a bad
way
and then put some fail safes in it to to
just kind of you know
so so it's like a hackathon where
hackathon exactly
yeah if i have a a secure system i
invite in the world's best hackers see
if they come on into it try it
okay we'll fix that there's a hole
there's and whoever cacks in they get a
reward
absolutely yeah and now that that
bulletproof's my system okay so we need
more of that
i think we need more of that but i also
think like fashionability and trends
there's a cultural pressure on certain
technology
it's like you think like like i talked
about glass holes before
that was just cultural pressure that
ended that you know
or or beta versus vhs
you know what i mean like people just
randomly decided
how old are you how old are you
i i just applied for medicare you guys
okay
i look really good for my
[Laughter]
we'll do it but i think from the onset
as we're making the innovation we should
start to think those hard questions how
can the how can this be misused
you know okay is there a technology an
eso that you are
currently worried will be misused in the
future
well i'm a little worried about
driverless cars uh they are being sold
as wonderful ways to take us to places
and i think that's great but they're
actually ethical decisions that are
being made
in the algorithms so when the car is at
a place where it can possibly have an
accident
it will make a decision who it's going
to harm and uh
i think that's like the trolley car
analogies right
yeah well those are humans though but
this is an algorithm
and so i think that ethicists and
philosophers should be part of that
decision making when they talk to
computer scientists like what is the
best way because right now it's a couple
of people with low grade body odor who
are making these decisions
so what you're saying is if a car is
going to hit two people by veering right
or one person by varying left it will
make a decision
i want to make a decision i would hit
the one person possibly kill them but
then i
we're net plus one life by that decision
right right
but but as you know i used to be a
lifeguard they would say look if there's
an
old person and a young person who's you
know in trouble
choose the younger person i don't know
if the algorithms are doing that
so we need some human interface in there
too
interesting i don't want you to be my
lifeguard
i wouldn't save me
all right couple weekend time for like
two more real quick okay um
sorry sorry um oh what do you think oh
sorry this comes from
mineco hasagawa on instagram what do you
think has been the single biggest missed
opportunity for a technological
advancement due to other factors
i.e death of the inventor
socio-political factors such as war
disease or lack of funding
that's a good question yeah um i think
we've capitalized on most
inventions um i can't think of one that
hasn't been capitalized uh
even with death like i'm thinking about
dna uh you know
we we stole rosalind franklin's picture
uh
so people always capitalize on
inventions i don't i can't think of
anything off the top of my head of where
some
where there was a lost opportunity just
to clarify rosin franklin
was uh oh sorry co-discover co-discover
the dna of dna
and had this wonderful picture that
explained how
things were arranged she had it to the
side it was actually
taken for lack of a better term uh she
didn't get the nobel prize but
you know we all know what the watson and
crick did but i think they're doing a
biopic on her if they haven't already
i'm glad there's actually yeah a couple
of films yeah she should get getting her
due
so for me uh the way i see this and i'm
unfortunately gonna have to wrap here
is um it's not so much that there's a
single invention that could have been
further exploited and was not
i think there's an entire slowdown
that comes about by people who a rising
population of people who are just simply
anti-science
and they think science somehow has made
their lives worse
when half of them are actually alive
today
and wouldn't have been alive 200 years
ago because science
health medicine
security all of this have been brought
about so if you have movements that are
anti-science
anti-technology that's going to slow
things down
and and you don't even know what you
could be benefiting from
because it's not there to for you to
benefit from it i mean it's one of these
things
so that i'm that's my worry that
civilization could be in a more advanced
place than it already is
simply because of these these regressive
forces
in society well that's why we didn't get
on board with the electric car
right like in the 80s or whatever the
electric car was trying to be a thing
and then all the forces were like no
thank you
and right right and then now here we are
like 20 years later with the electric
car becoming a thing
and electric car was an idea back in the
night in the 1920s people thought about
it because the electricity was
becoming more and more available but by
then like you said beta
uh data versus video yes it's got vhs
they got vhs
so anissa take us out with some quick
words of wisdom
well technology is all over us and and
they've always been used as a way to
advance humankind but
what i talk about in the alchemy of us
is that we are in a dance with
technology
we create them and then they create us
and so it's all
it's up to all of us to make sure that
these technologies are actually moving
us
in the directions that we think is best
for all of humanity oh that's beautiful
can't top that
uh we've got to end it there so anissa
ramirez great to have you back on star
talk
thank you could you write more books so
we can bring you one more often
just that we'll probably find another
way to
we'll invent an excuse to bring you back
on and nagin farsada
uh we really enjoyed you for this and oh
thank you
i hope you come back i would love to
come back also anissa i just want to
pitch to you that the alchemy of us
should be a spin-off series to this
is us but it's like a family of
scientists
oh no nice idea when you heard it here
first
all right cut it there i am neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
this has been star talk cosmic query
engineering edition
as always i bid you to keep looking up
you